[Music]
[Applause]
as well
yesterday we had nick wright on and uh
he's one of our favorites he's a co-host
of first things first
and uh he used to live in houston and
we somehow got around to barbecue
because he loves the kansas city chiefs
and he talked about houston barbecue is
not
very good come to kansas city for the
barbecue jj
stay for the championships that would be
my recommendation
well you have lived in houston so you
you are yeah i lived there for four
years and ate what they
listen houston folks i understand it's
been tough times
i empathize with you immensely but texas
barbecue
is fraudulent and not it's not like
bad compared to its reputation it's bad
compared to food
it's just not good
that's nick wright yesterday so paulie
goes i got somebody who's going to help
us here he's the barbecue edit
editor of texas monthly magazine daniel
vaughn joining us now
and the author of the prophets of smoked
meat a journey through texas barbecue
co-author of whole hog barbecue he's uh
uh sampled over 1800 barbecue joints
most of which are in texas and daniel
kind enough to join us daniel your
reaction to nick wright
calling texas barbecue fraudulent
oh man i heard it yesterday you just
played it for me now
like i feel personally attacked i mean
fraudulent like
is it fraudulent because like in in
texas and houston and austin and dallas
fort worth wherever you are
we cook with wood instead of cooking
with gas like most of the big names in
kansas city
is that what's fraudulent about texas
barbecue
i i just i can't can't even wrap my head
around it
okay kansas city gets credit for maybe
the best barbecue
first of all explain what kansas city
barbecue is and
does kansas city deserve that high of a
ranking
well what high of a ranking i mean i
don't put it anywhere like
as a high ranking okay um i mean i mean
to me obviously texas barbecue is number
one um
and so then from the area i'd say you go
to north carolina
south carolina the whole hog barbecue
over there like
that's better than anything you're going
to get in kansas city now kansas city
they got a lot of options right they got
much like texas barbecue they actually
have some similarities you get your
brisket
your pork get your pork ribs um some
sausage you get all those things right
in both texas and kansas city it's just
that in texas is the one place where you
can get a good version of sliced brisket
i mean in kansas city it's just it's so
uh it's so tough they gotta slice it
with a deli slicer before they put it on
your tray
i mean in kansas city they argue about
barbecue sauce they don't argue about
which place has the best meat they talk
about which place has the best sauce
people who are ordering from kansas city
barbecue joints or ordering sauce to be
delivered to their house not the
barbecue
well that's what i wondered about what
you put on the ribs
or do you put nothing on the ribs
well in texas uh i mean most barbecue
here is served with sauce on the side
everybody serves barbecue sauce but we
don't try to cover it up like kansas
city right we don't want to cover up the
meat we want the sauce to be on the side
so the meat can stand on its own because
generally the meat can stand on its own
uh which is not
the case in kansas city what about
memphis barbecue daniel
i mean memphis barbecue is good but much
like kansas city it's like
you know texas barbecue for example i'm
i just got a photo from kyrgyzstan sent
to me
this morning of a barbecue joint in in
kyrgyzstan doing texas-style barbecue
like last week they were standing uh
in riyadh saudi arabia they're standing
in line for texas barbecue
it's like kansas city and memphis they
can't even get beyond their own city
limits
uh seton you had a question for daniel
well yeah i just think it's interesting
that we keep
like keep saying like memphis barbecue
versus texas barbecue
or kansas city barbecue versus texas
barbecue
whereas you're taking like a population
of 30 million people
and then comparing it to a population of
500 000 people and being like yeah we're
better okay how about we do a city
all right so i mean
austin austin houston fort worth
all cities with better barbecue than any
other city
in america if i was coming
to texas for a week what city would i go
to for the best barbecue
man well i mean for the all-time best
barbecue i mean
we do a top 50 barbecue list every four
years at texas monthly
and snow's barbecues at the top and
they're right outside of austin
franklin barbecue is right there they're
right in austin so i'd have to say
austin is the best place as far as like
getting the biggest bang for your buck
what makes snows the best
uh just the fact that they do everything
well like you can usually tell somebody
uh when they're going to a barbecue
joint like which thing to order that's
really going to wow you
and it snows it's like you can't break
it down like that it's like everything
is going to wow
like everything is spectacular and then
of course when you go you get to
you know see one of the most famous
texas pit masters
uh tootsie tominets who's 85 years old
now will be 86 this year
doing her thing at snow's bbq so that's
part of what makes it special too
should you avoid the sides because you
need to focus on the meat
yeah yeah i mean sides bread like all
those things like pickles
pickles are medicinal like pickles are
going to help you eat more
but all that other stuff like i mean if
you're going
for like just a big time barbecue tour
in texas yeah you wanna you wanna stay
away from all the sides
is there good barbecue in the north
well i mean hometown barbecue in
brooklyn they do a fantastic
job so i've got to say yes and i will
say too like there is
good barbecue in kansas city there's a
guy tyler harp he runs
a heart barbecue there and actually he
was so mad about an article that i wrote
about kansas city barbecue that said
some unkind
things about it that he came to texas
with his dad he was mad he's like i'm
going to prove this guy wrong
and he goes to austin eats the barbecue
eats at several different places
goes back home to kansas city and
realizes that his life's mission now is
to bring
texas barbecue to people in kansas city
so if you do want good brisket in kansas
city there is the one place it's heart
barbecue
and it's because they're cooking texas
style barbecue uh what about
los angeles los angeles um
let's see uh horn barbecue well that's
not los angeles that's in oakland that's
that's certainly
uh high on my list of places to go visit
um i mean i haven't had anything that
like truly wowed me there but then
moose craft bbq in los angeles is a
place that i haven't been able to visit
yet so
there is some good barbecue out there
but of course it's it's going to be
probably texas style daniel thanks for
joining us i love you're fired up and
i'll make sure that nick
wright hears what you had to say all
right i appreciate that thank you that's
daniel vaughn the barbecue editor of
texas monthly magazine
wow he has sampled smoked meats
at over 1800 barbecue joints most of
which
are in texas how about the fact that he
wrote a book called the prophets of
smoked meat a journey through texas
barbecue
he co-authored authored a book the whole
hog
barbecue the gospel of carolina barbecue